[Aplausos]
[Música]
california es algo así como el paraíso
en la tierra tienen playas sol hollywood
y encima están forrados si california
fuera un país independiente sería la
sexta economía más rica del mundo la
renta per cápita en esta zona del mundo
es de casi 70 mil dólares para que os
hagáis una idea esto es más del doble
que la española y diréis a ver a ver
pero no se supone que este vídeo va
sobre la crisis de california que crisis
pueden tener en un sitio donde parece
que el dinero crece en los árboles pues
atentos
el gobernador jerry brown dice que el
déficit presupuestario de california ha
vuelto hace menos de 4 años declaró que
el presupuesto de california estaría
equilibrado en el futuro próximo pero
este martes ha dicho que estima un
déficit de 1.600 millones de dólares
para el próximo verano
[Música]
stockton california es la ciudad más
grande de california en declarar la
bancarrota es verdad estas dos noticias
son de hace unos años la primera es de
2017 y la segunda es de 2012 en el
momento en el que hacemos este vídeo
california está en superávit pero es
pura casualidad quiero decir las
finanzas están bien en este momento en
el que el ciclo económico está alto pero
en el momento en el que la economía baje
un poquito california volverá a tener
una nueva crisis fiscal y creedme esto
no debería ser así las crisis van y
vienen pero las cuentas del estado
tienen que ser mucho más robustas más
que nada porque tanto los salarios de
los funcionarios como los servicios
públicos tienen que funcionar siempre no
puedes llegar un año y decir bueno
chicos que lo siento pero este año no
hay colegios públicos y se siente y
creedme normalmente las cuentas públicas
de los estados suelen ser mucho más
estables el caso de california es una
excepción así que la pregunta es cómo es
posible que california siendo el estado
con los impuestos más altos de todo eeuu
con más millonarios por kilómetro
cuadrado que casi ningún otro lugar del
mundo
tenga tantos problemas para llegar a fin
de mes hay una solución para este
problema y lo que es más importante cómo
afecta el déficit fiscal a la vida de
los californianos de a pie realmente
hablamos de un problema serio hoy vamos
a responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
la grecia de eeuu la primera pregunta
que nos tenemos que hacer es qué
significa exactamente el déficit
presupuestario pues es un concepto muy
fácil de entender estar en déficit
significa que gastas más de lo que
ingresas cuando ocurre el caso contrario
es decir que ingresas más de lo que
gastas decimos que estás en superávit y
cuánto gasta california pues bien el
presupuesto 2019 2020 son 209 mil
millones de dólares para que os hagáis
una idea esto es más grande que todo el
pib de grecia
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pero esto no es todo si analizamos la
tendencia veremos que el gobierno de
california gasta más y más cada año para
que os hagáis una idea el presupuesto
del año 2008 2009 era de 144 mil
millones de dólares y en 1990 era de 101
mil millones de dólares como veis se
dibuja una tendencia el gasto público en
california no para de crecer es más en
sólo 30 años se ha duplicado y a dónde
va todo ese dinero pues a un montón de
cosas por ejemplo california está
construyendo un tren de alta velocidad
que conecta a los ángeles con central
valley y el presupuesto no deja de
inflarse
[Aplausos]
[Música]
otro ejemplo en el curso pasado
california se gastó casi 5.000 millones
de dólares en servicios humanos y de
salud 3 mil 800 millones de dólares para
sanidad especializada en niños y otros
200 millones para el cuidado de los
mayores mientras tanto cuanto diríais
que se ha gastado texas en estos
menesteres en los últimos 10 años mil
millones cien millones un millón de
dólares
la respuesta es cero patatero por
supuesto que texas gasta en servicios
públicos pero muchísimo menos dinero y
todas las partidas que hemos mencionado
antes ni siquiera existen en el
presupuesto tejano significa esto que
california hace mal en gastar en este
tipo de cosas por supuesto que no creo
que todos estamos de acuerdo en que está
bien cuidar de los niños y los ancianos
el problema pues que para pagar todo eso
necesitas impuestos y en la mayor parte
de los años el estado californiano no
recauda lo suficiente
[Música]
si es el mismo problema que tienen en
otros países como grecia o españa y la
pregunta es en qué medida afecta esto a
los ciudadanos de a pie pues la
respuesta es que depende por ejemplo si
estás viendo este vídeo desde san
francisco y vamos a decir que trabajas
para google o facebook ni siquiera te
habrás dado cuenta
si estás en los ángeles y eres un actor
de hollywood seguramente tampoco esta es
la gran ventaja de california frente a
españa o grecia en este caso tenemos una
economía extremadamente diversificada
california tiene un sector agrícola
súper moderno un sector tecnológico que
es la envidia del mundo industria
cultural financiera y montones de
universidades en otras palabras que el
estado de california sean lo que es el
estado supone una parte muy pequeña del
pib total así que sus problemas no se
contagian tanto al resto de la sociedad
al menos no tanto como en otros sitios
como españa sin ir más lejos ahora bien
todos aquellos que dependen de las
ayudas públicas si tienen problemas y
problemas serios pero de eso vamos a
hablar más adelante porque la pregunta
que nos tenemos que hacer primero es y
porque california recauda tampoco lo
hemos dicho antes que tiene
los impuestos más altos de eeuu
[Música]
y así tienen los tipos más altos de todo
el país pero mis queridos amigos de
visual política cuando hablamos de
impuestos el tamaño no es lo único que
importa por ejemplo california y en el
impuesto de la renta más alto de todos
los estados con tipos tan altos como el
13% si puede parecer un poquito bajo
pero pensad que a este 13% hay que
sumarle los impuestos federales para que
os hagáis una idea después de california
el estado con los tipos más altos sobre
la renta es hawai con un 11% y tanto
florida como texas directamente no
tienen impuestos sobre la renta y lo
mismo pasa con los impuestos de
propiedad de ganancias del capital o
incluso de sociedades sin embargo el
impuesto sobre las ventas lo que en
españa y en muchos países de
latinoamérica llamamos el iva es mucho
más bajo que en casi cualquier otro
estado porque pues porque en california
quieren asegurarse de que sean los ricos
quienes más paguen al poner impuestos
altos en los sueldos millonarios de
estos grandes empresarios o en las
ganancias de los inversores de silicon
valley california se asegura de que son
los grandes magnates quienes más
contribuyen al presupuesto total y las
como son california tiene más magnates
que bares tiene españa muchos pensaréis
que todo esto son bonitas palabras pero
lo cierto es que no para que os hagáis
una idea en el año 2004 el 3 por ciento
más rico pagó el 60 por ciento de la
recaudación total en otras palabras que
california tiene uno de los modelos
fiscales más progresivos que existen
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
y dónde está el problema a mí me suena
muy bien que paguen más los que más
tienen verdad pues el problema viene en
que la renta de los ricos fluctúa más
que la de ningún otro grupo por ejemplo
cuando la economía va bien las empresas
normalmente generan un montón de
beneficios y por tanto pagan muchos
impuestos de sociedades recordad que el
impuesto de sociedades es un impuesto al
beneficio pero qué pasa cuando viene un
mal año pues que las empresas dan
pérdidas y por tanto no tienen
beneficios sobre los que pagar impuestos
algo parecido pasa con los impuestos a
las rentas del capital cuando la bolsa
sube pagas mucho pero si la bolsa baja
pues no pagas un duro por poner un
ejemplo suecia que también es un país
con impuestos muy altos no tiene estos
problemas de estabilidad porque porque
en suecia los impuestos están mucho más
diversificados por ejemplo el iva en
este país es del 25% esto es tres veces
más alto que el iba en california qué
ventaja tienen los impuestos indirectos
pues queda igual como este el ciclo
económico tú vas a seguir teniendo que
ir al supermercado a comprarte ropa o
irte de vacaciones tal vez compres menos
pero seguirás comprando en otras
palabras que la recaudación es mucho más
predecible y que pasa en california pues
que como la recaudación fluctúa una
barbaridad dependiendo del año tenemos
dinero o no lo tenemos y muchos
pensaréis vale fonseca pero gracias a
esta política fiscal california es mucho
más justo que texas seguro que es un
estado mucho más igualitario donde el
gobierno cuida de los desprotegidos y
existe igualdad real verdad pues ahora
mismo vais a ver lo que pasa de verdad
[Música]
la nación de los sin techo no es que
california sea desigual es que es
terriblemente desigual para que os
hagáis una idea california es el cuarto
estado en desigualdad económica de todo
eeuu es más 7 de las 15 ciudades con más
desigualdad de todo el país están en
este estado y por eso es tan normal
encontrarse noticias como esta
los sintecho han crecido en un 75% en 6
años pasando de 32 mil a casi 55.000 por
supuesto que el déficit público no es la
única razón para explicar tanto sin
techo parte de este problema se explica
por los enormes costes de las casas para
que os hagáis una idea en todo eeuu el
alquiler medio de un apartamento de dos
habitaciones es de 1.175 dólares en san
francisco es de tres mil ciento sesenta
y cinco dólares casi tres veces más alto
en general california es un estado muy
caro y da igual si hablamos de comida o
transporte y los sueldos tampoco crecen
tanto como cabría esperar para que os
hagáis una idea una persona que
estuviera cobrando 15.000 dólares al año
en 1980 tendría un salario bajo pues
bien ese salario bajo hoy sería de
17.700 dólares sin embargo una persona
que estuviera cobrando 100 mil dólares
en 1980 ahora estaría cobrando 222 mil
dólares
podéis ver cómo han crecido las
desigualdades salariales
[Música]
otro factor importante para explicar la
enorme población de sintecho es la
migración interna dicho de otra forma es
mejor ser un sintecho en california
donde hace buen tiempo que será un
sintecho en chicago del día de frío todo
el año así que muchos vagabundos
terminan mudándose aquí y la pregunta es
qué hace el gobierno de california con
todos estos sin techo pues literalmente
nada porque pues simplemente porque es
que no hay dinero por ejemplo una ciudad
como oakland puede ofrecer refugios pero
solo durante seis meses y hace falta
ganar un sorteo para poder entrar por
hacer una comparativa en la ciudad de
nueva york el 95% de los vagabundos
tiene albergue en seattle hablamos del
60 por ciento san francisco apenas tiene
albergues para el 40% de sus intensos y
todo esto qué problemas trae pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
la pesadilla california no lo volvemos a
repetir california es un lugar
fantástico y muy próspero lo que estamos
contando son lo que llamamos problemas
del primer mundo pero aún así siguen
siendo problemas con tantas bolsas de
pobreza coste de la vida que sube y poco
dinero disponible para hacerlo frente
con políticas públicas es normal que
terminen ocurriendo cosas como esta
a la basura a las jeringuillas usadas y
los restos orgánicos han generado un
crecimiento de la población de ratas y
junto a ellas moscas y enfermedades
mortales en 2008 se encontraron 13 casos
de tifus y en 2018 han llegado a 167
mientras tanto la hepatitis a la
tuberculosis y los estafilococos se
expanden en los ángeles san francisco y
otras ciudades californianas exacto en
algunas zonas de california están
teniendo problemas sanitarios si a éste
le añadimos el repunte del consumo de
drogas opiáceos tenemos una postal muy
pero que muy desagradable como os podéis
imaginar todos estos problemas sociales
generan descontento protestas y sobre
todo radicalismo
[Música]
21 arrestados en una manifestación en
contra de un mitin de donald trump que
se celebraba en vertele
manifestantes se enfrentan a cargos de
asalto por una protesta violenta que
dejó a 10 heridos en 2016 exacto
california está cada día más polarizado
entre dos extremos extrema izquierda y
extrema derecha ver que leí san
francisco que siempre han sido lugares
de debate intelectual están dando paso a
un caldo de cultivo perfecto para los
extremos y todo esto explica que muchos
californianos estén abandonando su
estado para que os hagáis una idea en el
año 2018 más de 700.000 californianos
emigraron a otros estados como idaho
texas o colorado y diréis para ver
fonseca si la población de california
está creciendo todos sabemos que la
población de california aumenta año tras
año pues si tenéis razón pero es que
todo esto se explica con la inmigración
internacional es decir en 2018 690 mil
californianos se marcharon y 500.000
estadounidenses de otros estados
llegaron pero es que otros cientos de
miles de mexicanos guatemaltecos y en
general gente de todas partes estaba
entrando en el estado porque como
decíamos al principio todo lo que os
hemos contado son los llamados problemas
del primer mundo pero una cosa está
clara
el gobierno de california tiene mucho
que mejorar así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que california será
capaz de resolver su déficit crónico o
tal vez estamos ante el principio del
fin de la era dorada de california
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]